get over here
welcome hello
this is peter brown my name is rob
handlery it's true this is true and this
is triforce we are playing zelda breath
of the wild a little differently today
today but
we're going to go to event tide island
even tide island even tide i want to say
event because it is a big event it's
kind of an event it's a very much event
however i'm sure you guys know of this
place uh it's kind of got like a
perma-death
takes all your armor away
they really strip you down
uh however
we are doing it a little
differently
with only powers as in the runes
this
is our palette today and that's gonna be
it
uh
we do have the four so excuse me we have
the four other powers that we might use
if it gets a little sticky and hairy
gross gross indeed
but we're going to try to do just with
runes yeah i'm going to let rob steer
the ship as it were uh because he's uh
he's done this before yeah i'm gonna
show me the ropes a little bit sure and
i think we'll switch off every death
um you there is a leaf if you yeah i was
gonna say you don't have it right nope
but i'm willing to bet that you don't
have any weapon slots i'm willing to bet
you can get rid of that forest dweller's
sword
get get get these crabs
okay
uh yeah drop uh i don't care drop
whatever you want just don't save my
game
you can drop everything
damn
no
let's drop this
all right
we're off
nope
nope
why is it so difficult
i don't know
hey that was weird i was doing i was
doing it
we're off to a great start
our voyage begins
now
uh so how is your breath of the wild
playing going outside of the stream
because i know i'm starting to
play a little less these days
yeah i
would concur as far as uh my attitude
towards it you know and the thing is i
still haven't been gannon and i'm just
like what the hell i don't know dude
every day i feel like i leave the office
i'm doing it tonight i don't you're an
adult
possibility seriously
um
i literally either get sidetracked or i
like whoa
or i like
um
i'm like or i do like prepping i like i
set stretch goals i'm like all right i'm
gonna get all these arrows or i'm gonna
like try to do this and then end up just
going to bed
um you really are an adult
[Laughter]
but if you guys are watching um you guys
can
leave your comments in the youtube
and or twitch chat
yes
this is episode five
six yeah
last week uh
maybe the best stream we've done yet uh
i put the hat over on there you got the
hat up there oh look at that it's almost
i can get my head it's almost like i'm
wearing it
nice not quite uh yeah we played
blindfolded wearing an oversized hat
and um it was disaster but we also
accomplished our goal
uh you should probably go back and watch
that it's pretty funny
all right peter this is where it begins
[Laughter]
they hired that guy for 10 seconds and
then he left the studio
perfect we're good all right so all
right
beyond the lack of armor what makes this
so challenging
well
you got nothing what makes it so
challenging well you got nothing man you
got no weapons you got
you got no shoes on i would hate to be
on an island with no shoes oh
you can't oh you're right get rid of
that branch i don't want it this is
really garbage this is really weird
okay uh dude it's just challenging man i
mean like yeah no armor no weapons like
that's enough so but explain the
challenges oh okay
uh so there is a shrine you have to
raise it from the earth uh and uh if you
know a lot of the keys or
puzzles aspects of this game is like
bring the orb to the keyhole sure and
there are three orbs three keyholes
and they're in sticky situations
harry you might just say
you did
oh okay so there are enemies and we're
off but
okay yeah so only
you bunch of idiots there is a god
all right well that was pretty great
what did he do
he picked up the bomb and he walks near
the fire maybe
well there
man i'd love to see the replay of that
so i mean i could do stuff like this
tell me
oh you know what i should do though
honestly is uh
cook and make some
din all right
uh i should start gathering because i
got nothing my uh
oh bait
oh they're talking about yeah so you'll
see i think i've alluded to this there
is uh one of the keys is around
a henix
neck
right and i never even like thought
about
oh i dude these are probably the most
annoying games annoying games uh i'm not
speaking correctly annoying guys of the
whole freaking game they have a really
long uh reach yeah
so all right so this is the guy
is that is that bull gonna wake his ass
up
no he's a pretty heavy uh sleeper all
right so there's things we can do i mean
i we could i'm gonna sneak it
could you like paraglide on his belly
and grab it
oh that's right you can do that i would
people he's gonna wake up though
so he
he's got like two states of waking up
there's one where it's like
he'll go right back to sleep if you
don't if you don't do anything right the
other one is he's already gonna look at
this party wow
[Music]
they even invited the two two toys damn
this is going pretty freaking well i'm
waiting live
bombs man
i mean we also got the stasis too so
yeah
are you into them
come on come on
doesn't this feel so freeing to not have
to like guide each other when we're
doing this oh my god yeah so last week
we uh one of us was blind and the other
was playing it was some of the most
intensive work on on my our brains like
i think we've ever done where are you
going i have like post-traumatic stream
disorder from that yeah
dude it was yeah the worst was that one
time i keep saying it was when we
accidentally woke up a henix because a
guardian was chasing us
i thought we were just done i was like
actually concerned the stream was just
going to be done
questioning all your life decisions
come here you got them
i love their death cry yeah
it's kind of sad they're kind of
they're kind of like humanized like they
i like when they have convos
it's like what are they talking about
meat mostly
i imagine
[Music]
so well can i can i light this on fire
with a torch can i throw the torch yeah
sure
i'll allow it
could there have been another way
we will never
know all right let's cook some some
stuff here throw some teeth in there for
good measurement
tight chilly
[Music]
yummy
yeah if you guys are just joining us for
playing uh breath of the wild here
do you want to try to fight him with the
objects that are laying around or do you
want to try to sure i mean like a
stealthy way yeah
i mean we could do different things
all right
i mean we could well so the thing is i
mean i guess i can only use bombs right
so i can't you can push that over i
think i don't i don't think it'll it'll
hit him though oh we can try one
come on
oh yeah that's him in the knee
[Music]
so the question is will he then go back
to sleep he will
these guys are known idiots you can't
get me up here
what's your plan
it's annoying he hates that
oh my god i think he's got a plan
oh
hey fun
all right
well uh
you're ready to rumble
you won't see me here though
i can smell you anywhere
see he doesn't know where i am
[Music]
oh can you stay uh he won't stay stasis
for long though as long as he can find
him off the cliff
oh look at this big dumb idiot
[Music]
why you guys not use weapon felix
because that's today's
challenge finish this island with no
weapons
[Music]
i mean we're going to be here all day
i mean i should i can leave just leave
them yeah leave him come back
he's so slow later
so anyways yeah so he's got one of the
keys
um
[Music]
if it's a weapon i'll throw something
you can't use
hey butterbean
chuck that in the ocean
uh
oh he's oh he's already asleep again
what a baby
so we'll see how this oh paragliding
yeah yeah
uh ryan double nine double s why not
sneak down stasis him while he's asleep
and take the orb he does not stay stasis
for very long so we are going to uh
paraglide down and try to
wrench it from his neck
ike
martin there
there's your shadow bud how you doing
all right here we go
you have to like catch yourself the last
second i feel like i know yeah
gentle as she goes oh
what a breeze
[Laughter]
there he goes
all right well that's why we made some
oh no
what
oh yeah these aren't really good dishes
oh shoot
you could grab that ball but you can't
sprint with the ball no
whoa he's little
yeah yeah lure him away
let's see what he does
all right guys dang it i think if you s
oh he likes that tree
[Music]
dude look at that that guy is aiming for
you
i know right they're they're so
freaking great at leading too
all right all right oh
run back i would run back grab that
keep him a little bit distracted if you
can
what does he do with the tree now
cool if you like you don't want to know
[Laughter]
it just is back so there were times when
i played this this took me really long
probably too long than it really should
uh there were times where i the key i
would lose the key
uh
due to something like this i would go
back and i wouldn't be able to find it
and i would have to restart and it would
be the last of the three so that was
like 30 minutes
it was freaking odd
it's all right i think if you yeah if
you lure him this way and then work your
way back
you should be able to grab it and run up
there right yeah
rebecca lemke wants to know when do we
start the stream each week thursdays at
11 a.m pacific time
specifically
you should probably go back he can't
he's not going to chase you this far
that's that's the thing you can only
lure him a certain distance
how could you go to sleep in this
weather
oh my god
oh yeah nice dodge
do it do it do it do it do it do it
can you see me god that's all right dude
let him chase you and then go back and
get it i know that's what we're doing no
but you keep going too far
if you go if you if you make too big of
a gap between you two he's not going to
chase you that far so you have to kind
of like war him you know because you're
faster anyway so if he can follow you a
certain distance you can get back to the
thing faster than you can
[Music]
right so that seems to kind of cut off
you have to
[Laughter]
the miscommunication is real i don't
understand what you're exactly talking
about let me let me do it then let me
show you what i'm saying
sorry
all right
let's see
uh yeah why are they just dead on the
ground
crab life
oh you got it now i mean
where's that
where those come from easy easy easy
pouch no no no i was i was trying to
show you my strategy all right we'll
show it
you might wanna
those jellies are gonna hurt you
uh garth hunter we are trying not to use
weapons on the island yeah that's all
right your strategy would be
correct
it's raining you got it easy
and i think it's pouring you're not
snoring
nice one and i suck
there you go dude you should just do it
you play
you need to experience this i do
as i did
that durian up there is calling my name
you should actually get that yeah
um you know what if it if it's lightning
oh wow you can get pretty far
oh it didn't look like it
yeah
yeah mostly because i just don't like
him anymore yeah i know he's a he's a
douche there you go
uh-huh uh-huh no i don't know
all right dude
that's one
[Music]
so so
uh you're gonna want to make your way
up there
that tree just ate it yeah
trees
am i right
uh everyone if you are watching this is
triforce yeah
we're uh we're doing eventide island uh
a little differently we're gonna only
use our powers and see what goes so far
it's going pretty well aside from the
failure to
put phoenix to sleep
um
look at all you guys saying where you're
from
rob
16 10 he says greetings from australia
it's 4 20 a.m
you do need to sleep though he says i
need to sleep yeah at some point
okay there is a mob in here and a lot
more guys so it's all right yep look at
me
i'm looking
easy
oh sorry
food you want to eat you want to eat but
just bear with me dude one more hit
buddy dude buddy
[Music]
eat rob
no oh whoops nope that's
we're gonna have a problem with that
[Music]
you got some hot dishes
all right now we're out of health
yep this one's tough
like you should you should stack two
oh dang
this guy wants it
[Music]
oh
and now we restart
yep that's fine the helix is easy he
knocks the enox is easy
uh should we go back to the hinox then
because he is the easiest
i'm more inclined to do him over with
to do him last well yeah so yeah sure
that's what i mean okay come back to him
like after the fact oh sure
should we oh what we should save when
we're out there yeah dang it
that's a bust
should we allow the use of a leaf for a
weapon
it's not really a weapon
how does push enemies back sure that's a
good point uh the chat can decide if
do you guys think we're allowed to use
the korok leaf
i think this fit you have is legit yeah
dude i love your
matching
that kissing sound is no good
yeah
hey
come on
alan says that
[Laughter]
no we can't save on eventide but we can
do it right before yeah so we don't have
to do this crap again
no one leave
uh
bob jones i could cheating yeah no one
saying no no on leaf
whoa
oh now you're cooking you guys are kind
of terrible this game do it yeah come on
come on
pros
well
this is good enough
you're cool with this i'm cool with it
booyah
we're cruising now
the leaf is a lie
wow we're bucking it out ferrous on
one's uh again mentioning you can bring
weapons on the ship but we are trying to
not use weapons just using runes today
so
hence the challenge hence triforce we're
trying something out
majority says no on the leaf says joel i
agree yep
all right
how many deaths so far one death uno
this is a long intro
[Music]
yeah
oh
[Music]
suck
[Applause]
it yeah
for no good reason yeah
this is so great look at this oh bananas
galore garner
i'm surprised there's not a uh a yiga
ninja just like camped out here
welcome to my farm
just sleeping on a bunch of bananas
all right so we got nanners
oh this was a cool area oh crap
[Music]
come here come closer
whoa
woof
uh
first time i did that
was not great because this is oil and i
didn't know that
and i was like real close i had like two
orbs down just like i just kept dying
like a pit jerk
all right so
i know this much is there's an orb
first this
guy then
that guy
[Music]
and then we're good i think there's
another guy somewhere but
what's your
okay okay oh i'll do this
[Music]
oh
like a glove
i can't remember if after you complete
this you you have
any of the pickups
oh like if oh some stuff you would have
gotten yeah like i don't know if it like
just
i would assume no
[Music]
[Music]
how about another
you seem to like it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah my turn
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]
so where does that one go
this wasn't the area i died in right
this was
no
so
this one
this took me a while actually now i
think about it because i know there's
there's one way over here actually if
you came into the island you actually
saw it i don't know if you remember oh
yes
oh these guys beach party
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so about this meat
yeah they're having such a good time oh
what a dick
oh my god that dude
persistent
hmm
oh my god that's right this took me so
long
oh jesus do you have to do what i think
you have to do
well oh okay i got you i got you so
cryosis like
yeah yeah yeah
this was really tough okay
[Music]
great
like i had the ball like basically just
like leave like
like
take off into the water oh god
man
uh
there might be an easier way to do this
i don't know if chat remembers um
freeze explode freeze explode
but like yeah how do you
oh make it float in the water
do that underneath the ball
that's a good call
there you go
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
what's the easier way throw the ball and
freeze under okay yeah people say that i
mean that that works if if i get to it
quick enough i may have to stasis the
ball oh
but no like so freeze it
as it rises and then then faces yeah
let me get it better
switch
gotcha
will he hop
he will hunt
should i throw it yeah
my gut says yes and
[Laughter]
not gonna lie i knew that was gonna
happen
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa
there we go yeah perfect
you did it
[Music]
so we uh rob that said we could have
spaced it and whacked it but with what
we got nothing to whack it with that's
true a bomb
yeah maybe but that's so precise yeah
we're gonna hurt ourselves
and at this rate we're probably gonna
finish this sooner than we thought
but there is a shrine we have to
complete right
uh
i don't think that i think that's it i'm
pretty sure the shrine you know you know
the these this is the challenge right
here this is the shrine right there's
not a shrine after house oh okay you
know what i mean i thought i misheard
you earlier then oh i can't remember
yeah i'm pretty sure
let's let's go for this one on top of
the ridge here
this one seemed a little intense so the
the challenge is to get that
plate
off of the
the ball bucket
ah keyhole keyhole
okay master
oh goser
exactly
all right
talk about a hole in one
it's gotta be such a
work on your fingers dude his nails
some nubs probably yeah probably
like he doesn't have nut nails
we were talking earlier about like
thinking okay maybe we're starting to
slow down our playing with this game but
man dlc is just a few months away i i
sometimes my imagination runs wild with
what that could be i really hope it's
like substantial
yeah i hope it's not just like
another you know something like this
right just like oh yeah one more of
these i think it's going to be
over here
this area
it could be i mean because even on this
part of the map that you're highlighting
if you zoom in
so it names let me go a little bit
higher oh you're kidding
what
there were names on
oh no no no i'm i'm totally sorry it's
this part so you can't even go here oh
yeah you're right yeah yeah i tried
doing that yeah yeah yeah absolutely
right the mountainous stuff right so
like like this like the hebrew west
summit you can't get to the hebrew west
summit technically yeah
when i tried climbing there the game
would i would get to a certain point
just shh
that promises like you can't go anymore
yeah more dude you're done
all right what more do you want from me
yeah seriously
this is perfect the mask of rain
and i'm gonna get
oh yeah oh yeah what's going on who's
wearing it who's got it oh
moblin
[Music]
you should know better
[Laughter]
what an idiot nailed it nailed it now
can we throw a weapon as a lightning rod
or is that cheating because we're not
using it as a weapon per se
uh
chad would have to
answer that chat if you think we can
well
whoa what is he doing you're taking a
dumb
link
one day
um
i think we're losing
time
come on uh oh
great
can you blow up the barrel
i could double gobble gobble i could
have done that
all right this is gonna be harry
shut up
whoa
oh no woohoo
[Music]
there's so many lightning storms on the
on the forecast like these guys are
gonna get their
comeuppance
do they have yeah like this why isn't it
[Music]
less magnesis that guy's right
you catch that like we can use we could
use back pieces on an item yeah it makes
sense yeah that's a good call
oh okay i think i think blue boy is
about to get blown up
[Music]
oh yeah you're right
is he sniffing his sword do it
[Music]
oh crap
fly damn it
[Music]
that sucks because the lightning was
like a real big help
and people are debating if magnesis is a
weapon i'm debating my ability to play
this game
i should probably reload that save huh
i think we can do it
it's been a half an hour
35-40 minutes we made really good
progress in terms of figuring out what
to do yeah i'm just doing it for the
stream
you're just screwing up for the stream
what dang it
i guess maybe you can't save them all
the ocean
okay well i think yeah on a boat i guess
so save that makes sense because it's an
object so objects always reset no matter
your set your heart safe
so just get on a rock right before i do
it real
quick it's all about this weather hey my
boat is not agreeing you think you're
too close to the sail
too close to the sail yeah like
sorry that's wrong
yeah yeah
i
i am not going that fast hey this is
obnoxious
go
uh a death counter
[Music]
yeah if you're just joining us we are
trying to do even tide island with just
our wits and the powers
oh yeah get on that rock and do it
perfect
nice uh
oh
it's too late
that's right
because this time we're actually going
to do it
[Music]
like your idea it's core rock and a mic
it's like
damn dude that's really good
thanks thanks
[Music]
gannon is just a bunch of korrak
standing on each other's shoulders
you found us
okay so this is yeah right okay
crepe
we need those bananas i feel like we've
got to gather
food
let me get these yeah well that's the
other thing too
he's like come on
we have the ability to make dishes
what is this line the belief isn't a
weapon it's a lie
all right never use the leave
yeah i agree it's it's a bus that you
can't save but it makes sense
that would be cheating the even tied way
way what are you up to
oh
i can have a little fun right oh dude
you were allowed to have fun
really yeah
what yeah
that was [ __ ] but that guy looks
like he's got something cool the first
time that happened to me i yelled
that was the most
frustrating thing oh sick of it i just
want to see what it was
well where did it go it's dead no the
treasure chest that he was the treasure
chest no he had one in his head though
yeah exactly oh no he never has it it's
all
it's a little the treasure chest is a
lie the treasure chest is a lot
it's thoroughly disappointing
i agree
all right
we have died twice
but never again
my move here was pretty cool
you stasistan yeah stasis that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh super hot
this buddy's like
oh
that was pretty cool too right i like
that that was pretty that was pretty
cool who are you calling
who you calling one dude
whoops two
yeah
oh what
[Music]
there it is
you can turn off me
as grace we just did
[Music]
oh you know what i bet those powers
don't even work here
that's yeah that's a good point
he's made a real solid point
this guy's a jerk
i'm a bigger jerk yep
that's it
oh
oh man oh my god
[Music]
he's coming up
this is my house
oh
yep
i know what's gonna happen here oh come
on
really
oh
oh my god
oh my god please don't leave please
stick around
gosh i love it
[Laughter]
it's exaggeration
i do love it
oh because it makes it makes my
fails [ __ ]
not as impactful all right
sorry guys real quick
all right i'm committed to this now this
death counter yeah
ready for those anyone who's just
joining we are tackling even tide island
with just powers no weapons
uh no clothes
bob jones all about the death counter
sorry joey
i've let you down
let rob down more than anybody
oh you saved didn't you
no oh no it didn't work out that's right
um yeah i don't know where you can go
here because if you
i think if you touch anything it's gonna
just kick you
hey
he doesn't take any stamina uh
documentation
all right let's see
what
i mean i'm on the ground it says even
tight island
all right it should be fine
it doesn't matter because we're gonna do
it this time yes we will
like a hundred percent yeah we were just
kind of kidding around
yeah
to be made there
link
you know what's up
stop playing dome
we're doing it here we go
all right
yes
yes
i can kill this guy
whoa hey buddy
oh you can't do animals a couple of
horny boys over here
they literally have horns rob
i got it i love it
come here
that almost hurt
oh man if that killed me
not cool
stealth is your friend i agree with that
yeah
[Music]
all right we got some
[Music]
suck it
up
all right
all right
you know what the most disappointing
thing about that last death was i just
wanted to roll that bomb down those
stairs
yeah i was like oh i'm so clever
gratitude yeah inertia
[Music]
oh
it never gets old
all right he's kind of a dummy let's be
honest
[Music]
oh where's your bow
oh easy there
oh
[Music]
i think i died oh yeah i totally did
good we're doing good
yeah
i mean there's a steady we're improving
yeah sort of
i mean
should i just keep going i can come back
and do this just do now get over with
let's do now do not all right
what who's who's here
the music kicked in for the fire fire
oh we're gonna see a freaking octa rock
right on time
oh come on right in the butthole
oh my butt
wow that was the most childish thing
i've ever said no
everyone has a butt yeah that's true
versus to address the existence of a
butt i think is maybe the most mature
thing you can do damn
i love it
great
okay
okay
all right
all right this should be easy at this
point
oh
i can't see it i can't see it
oh look at it
oh you can actually turn it off i forgot
click on that you can like cancel it
the beat is so good
nope
swear to god like you cannot do that
like just walk around it like that just
like carefully with the uh with the joy
cons i feel like oh
control oh my god
go controllers just
do a jump and throw oh
wow i've never seen that happen
what dubious love it
that's one
cross nippolis krasnoplus is asking why
not use magnesis because those things
ain't magnetic my friend
rain's coming
storm's coming babo describe it to me
i'll describe this to you
yep yep yep yep
what no reaction
you've got to just set that thing off
thank you oh my god he just blew up
stephen no
man
all right
oh shoot he's right there oh dang what
was that
things are exploding
it's time to eat more fish for me
my buddies are dead it's time to eat
oh yeah that's good food yeah oh
stay away from that
what do you think volt fruit tastes like
burning
uh
not good
not good
it probably tastes like a red bull in
fruit form
i can't imagine that but yeah
yeah like you probably can't have more
than like two
yes or heart attack
all right
it's once again
lightnings
are coming
i mean at this point we should almost
use that to our advantage right right oh
you are okay sorry i didn't realize
which fill you were climbing
watch oh
that's good it's got to kick in we've
got three bolts on the horizon
come on
come on
my god get checked
is there anything we can drag oh i mean
you got those boxes over there
oh those aren't done
no there's not much i thought there was
one more thing that was metal around
here
he's got the same stuff
i just really want to see him get
shocked again
i want him to die
well yeah just maybe have to engage
oh my god
it's all right
jump
oh man on your feet oh
there should be like red stains in the
dribbling down
i look at your idea he just has nubs
it's all that i'm here
[Laughter]
oh my god
he's got like dysentery from eating all
this just rotten meat that's been like
half nod by moblins all the diseases in
their mouth just carried through
energetic
no you didn't see me nope it's a lie you
can't see me
oh well so much for the light
that's cool dumps the brakes
no
you blew it i did
i'm not gonna lie a little nervous
shut up the horn
[Music]
nice nice
[Music]
oh this guy
[Music]
nicely done
[Music]
man
yep
[Music]
oh look he loves it
you're not that fast
[Music]
ah
crazy food left
that'll help oh you got
get
plenty
just really
don't want
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
oh well that was a bad throw
oh or was it
[Music]
no damn
shut up
get off your ass and do something
a little bit of this
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
excuse me for the mic
uh-huh no
it should be square
it's not too late oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
shut up
get over here pick it up get over here
get over there get over here
oh man you can totally blow him off the
cliffs
[Music]
that'll do
i thought you're going to blow that
thing up accident i was like no
all right all right last guys
take them out
put them out of their misery
[Music]
i'll stay assistant
[Music]
you're gonna love this oh
oh that must kill me
last but not least
i think it's gonna be smooth sailing
after this i think you might be right
i am
horrified
if i mess this up now
i kind of want you to
i'm not gonna lie dude don't say that
[Music]
oh this was oh i i killed myself doing
this one great here we go
all right so
if we're not gonna use
oh you know we'll do
we'll put some of these red barrels
underneath it
yeah because like two bombs isn't
actually enough to get that slate up
right
oh man these things are dangerous
i mean here right i guess yeah i mean
any yeah
all right so then how do you
you can't blow those up with just
regular bombs right yeah yeah oh you can
yeah okay
i think that's fine
yeah i think you're right
but i would just you have to stasis that
thing first oh i do i'm just getting
prepped i'm gonna get one of them here
perfect sure
perfect stop
the thing about spheres
all right
i'm into that one
i don't like being near the stuff
this is scary
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oh no
oh yikes that was close
no that's not gonna do anything
i kind of like it
uh
how are we going to do this with not the
weapon um oh well there were more
barrels yeah kind of just oh there's two
there's two more there's two more yeah
okay
hmm
is there anything that we're not
thinking of i don't know
like is it
like i'm just in my own head i'm i'm
imagining it flipping like that yeah but
but maybe it's maybe just asking too
much right like maybe it's just like
pushing it like this way right right
because yeah
the path of least resistance
perhaps
so like but this won't stay but if you
do it like down yeah here
where's the other one
barrel yeah i think it's in the middle
that's good
pretty sure
oh i thought
damn i really did think there was a
barrel here
only we can make some
octo balloons
oh
um
that's a good call i don't have to we
have to go kill some
no this is the first time i've ever
wanted to go kill those guys yeah
we could try this one more time
yeah you might as well
because the octa balloon is not going to
make a difference between this tactic
it would be a whole other tactic but
even then are we gonna get enough
[Music]
yeah oh someone makes a good point drop
a box
from a great height
oh
try this bad boy out first though i know
this one's getting away from me that's
okay
well it's it really wanted to center all
the
explosive to center in one direction
right
well i think we kind of messed it up
yeah
whatever it's all right it's 4 20 a.m
again
it didn't do anything look at it there's
no direction on it great all right well
yeah let's drop some boxes okay what we
need the middle ones we need the metal
ones did you have any metal ones is this
oh there's a is that a boulder over
there
but you can't really pick ass on a metal
boulder
did you almost say metal boner
no i did not oh i wasn't thinking just
me then yeah
well there's a metal box over there
um
yeah
i don't even think that will do anything
lightning says you only need one octo
balloon
all right let's go find an octa rock we
know they are
[Music]
where are you oh i hear him i hear him
stupid kissy noise okay yeah yeah yeah
where's his dumb little plant head
which one is he
i only need one really that's what
they're claiming all right
should i get another one in case
uh yeah it wouldn't hurt i guess
um this guy's way out here though yeah i
don't know if i can get to him i mean i
could kill i think you can
[Music]
i would just throw a bomb because it
will roll across the water right the
float yeah you're right
nailed it
perf
what
what
that's all he had
really dang he just filled oh wait no
he's just filled with food no i'll take
it anyway
well let's give it a shot
you only need one people are saying all
right well i trust you guys
do i yes yes
mmm crab damn that does sound good right
now some crap yeah dude
this game definitely makes you hungry i
tell you like i when i made sushi for
the first time i just sat there and
looked at it and just went all right
this
so should i do it on the same side that
we were talking about earlier uh yes i
believe so i can call rock leaf it
we can't use leaf though
i guess you're right
god i hope this works like right here
yeah
yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah okay okay so you need to get
that orb for this oh no it should be
okay
i don't like this at all
i don't know what that's gonna do
oh man oh man
you're going to die you're going to die
oh man
it it can inch it like we can get it to
inch a little more like okay all right
let's get you
out of the line of fire
put it in the uh the bowl that's such a
good idea
do you think there might be balloons
inside of those crates
are there ever i don't know
tony tran says we have another balloon
do we
like we could just do this forever
we don't have enough that's that maybe
you think of this um these guts
like i could just do this again
no wrong way oh wait
that's gonna be
we're all right i can get a couple more
off here we're good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
we got this
what character was that i don't know
annoying uncle
i'll pick you up from school we got it
i don't think he needed
if you want to do it for good measure
sure
i think you get all the space you need
oh man
that almost hit me
[Laughter]
when it fell down that would have been
freaking the worst
or the best oh my god you're fine put
that in there
[Music]
i kind of feel like
so i had not done even tight island
before we got here
and i had built it up as this thing in
my head like super challenging
but it's like without weapons it's kind
of not that bad like once you just if
you know to be like on your game right
this almost seems like it'd be really
easy with weapons we think about other
things too like
doing this blind
like having no idea oh yeah like
not literally blind
but like
you're piecing together the island as
you go along and that is like
really difficult um as well but like i
know where everything is right like yeah
um
i also think the heart factor is a thing
because i did this really early on i
only had like maybe like six harps can
you get on his face and teabag him
dude maybe you can he's gonna
all right honestly
we're not done yet this guy can still
kill me like
when i was doing this once he like threw
his arm down and just hit me killed me
one hit
i'm like
nervous again i did throw it off right
uh yeah he did
he's not gonna
go back to bed
josh says it's not that hard
that boy's coming in tomorrow because
we're doing a perfect star wars stream
yeah star wars celebration a big event
happening in florida and uh we're
expecting a trailer for episode eight
so beforehand uh x game spot now twitch
josh shaw's gonna come by who's also in
the chat and uh me him and rob we're
gonna play old star wars games
such as pod racer rogue squadron and
the other one shadows of vampire oh we
are i mean yeah i just want to do the
code and then sure and then
uh and then we're also going to play on
pc
if we have time rebel assault two
that game is incredible if you've never
seen it before yeah and i think also
we'll toss in uh battlefront uh maybe an
original and then like the newest one
um
as that game is still really awesome
looking like
it's it's pretty fun it's a pretty game
it's pretty game um
yeah we got paw racer i loaded it up
today it is it's pretty funny to look at
that like just all the things you could
do like
i forgot you had to like buy it or you
could buy petroids
uh
just like look at your pod racer before
you raced i thought that was always neat
it's like all right cool all right games
that game's fun
[Music]
so this is the last one
um i'm going to do this
carefully
that goat is just asking
to fly off that cliff
he is isn't it
i would have snuck up on him
[Music]
man
idiot
oh no
oh you got this
yeah i mean i just
i've had these balls
disappear dude he's not going to get you
you you're faster than me
you're right i am awesome you're like
the jesse owens of zelda
oh that's right did we die one more time
i gotta i gotta add four uh
oh
i guess so oh
yikes
oh they were just hun
now they're hunting me
somewhere
guys hold on hold on hold on
okay let's play
this boy what up
yeah yeah yeah
your buddy's dead dude
how do you feel now
yeah
all right bloodlust that was two
can he do it
this dude he's just how to party by
himself well he's got these
weirdo boring
electric therefore
the party really gets started
oh my god can you imagine yes i can
i just want to look at this guy
who invited him who invited you
all right i'm milking it
yeah yeah what's up
brought snacks
how about another oh
nailed it
oh
oh
oh look he loved it
here we go
yeah all right
that's it
let's mess it up somehow
what do you know
bam
[Music]
again
that is the soundtrack to the office
every 10 minutes rob has some diddy
cooking
so what you go in here and you just
automatically get a prize there's no
puzzles
inside we just did the puzzle
what's the prize
i don't know
what are you good
i know let's find out we'll find out
and
we're back oh
come enter the shrine
well now we just gotta wreck this henix
yes you're right or should we stick to
that
no we need to we need to just like
obliterate him in the most brutal way
possible
and oh yeah
could you uh
um
let's say you could paraglide over him
and then do an overhead attack
uh
what do you got what do you got to eat
toenails toenails ice meat
fire fish
syrup fruit
get up
yo what up remember me
i do not yeah there you go 51.
[Music]
those are engineers
[Applause]
don't you cry about it saddlebags pants
on fire huh
that was annoying link character hey
buddy
what's in your eye
that was a bomb era wasn't it yeah oh
it's raining it's pouring that's why
do it do it
for that shotgun
nice shotgun
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
why not
why not
pretty good at these now oh
[Music]
oh throw the guardian weapon in his eye
all right
[Music]
tricky dick oh
learning huh
oh
that's right this is
[Music]
watch your move
stacy
[Music]
toenails for
days sneaky river escargot
i've never had it
is it good
you like it
uh the one time i had it was fine yeah i
mean it was seasoned it was cooked right
do we have the thunderhem
we do have the thing we do let's show it
do you have everything uh no
what are you missing do you know uh
missing
yeah dark link i'm missing a lot of the
like
you know green tunics from the various
games
um
i don't have all the zoro stuff
yeah that's worse stuff
get up
yeah we're just uh wrapping this up here
going to use uh
yeah that's a good call i keep man i
never use it even though i have it
i would be cool if that was like the
only power you got
yeah
the other ones are useful but they
almost kind of look too strong i that's
how i feel
link ravalli here what if it was super
long
hi link it's ravali i just wanted to
call in and let you know that you're
gayle yeah it's ready
bye
it's like in the middle of next message
like it's ravali again uh notice you
haven't returned my call just wanted to
make sure you got my first message
thanks
you have 123 messages from rivali here
lane kai
[Laughter]
hi link it's 4 20 a.m you're not
returning my call that's fine but what
christopher walken doing for volley
impression christopher walken is it
a link rivali here okay
here
link
you never return my calls
power's ready bye
ravali's here we should get coffee
okay bye no pressure
hey 300 rubies
that's it
yeah that's it
well that's
it that's it
yeah
we done did it well you done did it
thanks yeah we it was a combined effort
yes
well
sure thanks for watching everyone thank
you guys for watching
this has been triforce this has been
drive force i'm just gonna repeat
whatever you say um
yeah that was it uh
again if you guys uh have any ideas how
we can kind of play this
game differently um
let us know
yeah in the comments we'll check um a
couple of these have been um like this
one for instance was uh combined someone
said we could kill all mini bosses with
just runes right um so we kind of
thought well how else can we do that um
because it it's really hard to kill
someone as far as bosses go many
businesses so if you have any ideas let
us know in the chat here on youtube when
the video goes up uh and you can let us
know on twitter i'm at pc brown
and this guy yeah uh robert hanlery
all right thank you for joining us take
care see you guys have a great rest of
the week and again uh tomorrow we're
doing a star wars stream at 8 a.m yes um
we're gonna play a bunch of old star
wars games and uh lead up to 9 30 a.m
pacific where we are expecting to see
the first trailer for the last jedi star
wars
you